e
well this uh feels a little bit weird
but
um here we
are it's uh it's 11 o'clock and I will
um without a gavel I guess I'll use my
hand uh I will call to order the
subcommittee work
session of the education policy and
Administration uh committee here on
Monday March the 3D at 11:00 a.m. with
respect to house bille 131 and house
bille
Representatives Lichfield and
representative Hall as members
additional members of the of the
subcommittee um in conversation with
um I would like to point
out
that if you're if we're not already
aware um House Bill 781 is an early
Bill
therefore uh we need to take some action
as a
committee with respect to HB
781 uh no later than Wednesday of this
week um 131 does not operate under that
same
constraint now as I'm sure you have
observed as as we have
observed the language in HP 781 as
introduced and the language of 131 as in
introduced are identical
except that in house bille
781 the so-called early
Bill there is a section two beginning on
appropriation to open the work session
I'm wondering if there for the record is
there anyone who would like to speak to
either one of these bills from
the public no
okay um representative litfield or
representative Hall do you have any
comments that you would like to make as
part of an opening statement with
Mo thank you Mr
chairman what I'd like to say is you're
absolutely right the wording Within
These two bills is it's essentially the
same except for um the financial
distribution that we have available at
this point in time I would like to ask
the committee to please consider having
some type of funding available um so we
don't put an unfunded mandate out there
the governor has just been elected she
has asked that this be a priority um and
I would very much like to honor that
priority I realize that we only have a
couple of days until we need to make a
final decision on this we need to get
the um amendments by tomorrow but I
would love to even reach out to our
partners on the other side of the wall
and see if they have an appetite for any
type of funding as
you representative PA do do you have in
addition to any personal comments do you
have any uh are you at Liberty to share
what the disposition of your caucus may
or may not be with respect to either or
both of the bills yes um I think the
language uh oh so a couple things the
this applies to it says school districts
so it's only public schools and
wondering if we should be considering
Charter Schools as well um another or
private schools or whatever but at least
charter schools that' be one thing um I
know we talked
about uh you know the Bell to Bell and
all that stuff and I think that we
really needs to to um leave that with
local local control that initially I
think to start um that we have a we ask
school boards or board of directors or
whoever they are um to set a policy
about cell phones let's start there as
far as the money you know we understand
that um our governor has asked for um a
million dollars but that doesn't pay for
all students and I I almost think it's
too early to be spending the money I
mean I think we should start with a
policy that says hey this is what you
need to do you need to have a cell phone
policy and go beyond cell phones
actually and and include electronic
communication devices personal
electronic communication devices but not
tell them that you know just say it may
include Beyond so it's the cell phone
policy but it may include those other
devices um so I think year one um we're
not opposed to having money but whether
it's an unfunded mandate million dollar
is not going to get pouches for everyone
so I think our plan our position is if
we could have the Pol have the language
right now to say that this is what we
want you to develop a policy on I don't
even know and maybe you folks know what
does what does our governor think that
that million dollars is going to do what
answer I'm sorry we we can there only
only three of
us I'm sorry you mentioned a million
dollars is yes uh isn't the amount in in
in the bill 250,000 the bill is 2 is
right the bill so the bill is
250,000 the governor has put out there
$1 million um I tried to quickly look
this morning and I didn't have a chance
I was trying to look on the doe to see
how many middle and high school students
we have in the state of New Hampshire um
I I don't know as yet but $1 million if
we're going by what we we had we had
someone from pelum come in and speak
remember the pouch system that they're
using which seems to be the one that
they're using widespread throughout the
country right now that's $30 a pouch so
if you do the math a million dollars
divided by $30 that would give us
33,333
pouches so I don't know how many middle
and high school students we have so I
don't know whether that would cover them
all or not the basis of both of the
bills is for the state to take a
position that school boards need to
develop and adopt policy concerning
student cell phone use in
schools which we were reminded by the
last next to last person who testified
on the bill that we were hearing uh is
the next room with the anyway wherever
it is uh in committee about the state's
overall responsibility for
Education um therefore that would uh
require constitutional requirement would
be satisfied and would be in the
requirement would be in no way in
conflict with responsibility that the
state has for overall education policy
while at the same time respecting with
the language of both of these bills that
the specific policies that are developed
and adopted and implemented would be the
responsibility of the local school
boards do do we have a do we have
agreement with respect to the question
of State responsibility do we have
agreement that it would be appropriate
for us to have the state take the
position that school board should
develop adopt and Implement policies
with respect to cell phone usage in
school what I'm trying to do is build
this from the ground up yeah yes well no
sorry no yes I agree building it I
understand what you're saying um I if if
I may at this point may I just introduce
to you both the language that is in
house bill to in the budget I don't know
have you either of you seen it what the
governor has proposed no may I share
that with everyone so okay by the way
Melissa would you mind taking
notes um officially all I have to do is
fill out a subcommittee work session
report that I've just found out about
okay uh when I when I spoke to Chairman
cordelli about whether we needed a a
clerk he said well you have
representative Lichfield on the
committee and subcommittee and she
capably perform those duties for the
full committee so um while there is no
formal requirement for the uh submission
of of uh minutes or notes of this
meeting it might be helpful for our
recall and reporting to the full
committee uh in addition to any actions
we may take uh any anything else that
may be of interest so would you like
would you like to speak to this
um the handout that you've just given
us
yes so the gist of the handout is the
school board shall develop and adopt a
policy um but it would peroh personal
device used by students during the
school day and be implemented schoolwide
with approved exceptions determined by
student medical disability or language
proficiency needs this
also I believe it would go into effect
within 60 days that's the last line yeah
well the you you have the the dis ofit
it was just um there are exceptions for
504 if you have an
IEP there it also mentions the grant
program to be administered by the doe
which is similar to the language that I
had so so am I uh if I may then
represented all uh the ACT shall take
effect 60 days after its passage but
with respect to the school board shall
develop and adopt a policy
Etc uh there's no specification as to
when school boards what there's no
deadline by such and such a date is that
am I am I just recognizing that is that
something of concern
I mean we can we can direct school
boards to develop and adopt and I use
the word Implement uh policies governing
student cell phone
use but when do they have to do this I
think I think the word Implement is is a
magical word right they you can develop
a policy that policy states that this
will take effect in September 20 you
know it'll be up to the local school
districts I would think implementing
with a different story do we put a we do
we put in a buy after
implement or no later
six I
mean I think if if you don't tell people
when they have to do something or when
they have to do it if I told my kids
they needed to do something and they
didn't do it and I asked them why didn't
you do it the response that they would
give me frequently would be well you
didn't tell me when I had to do it by
but when it says this act shall take
effect 60 days after passed if the ACT
is you will develop not Implement you
will develop develop and adopt but lines
through East I know but where is this
this is from where where did it did you
is this your did you develop this I did
not devel where did this come from this
came from um the governor has put this
in the
budget the governor has put this
no but we don't
need this is just what she's thinking
correct right so I that's why I think
I'm going to go back and I don't think
our bill whatever we decide I don't
think it should be about implementation
I think it should
be adopt uh develop and adopt just like
we said here develop and uh and adopt
policy actually so there is a difference
between the we becoming a bit too uh
fine here by saying that um it the
word adopt would include Implement so
therefore we don't need to say
Implement can I just say the two of them
131 and 781 yes one's got enact yes and
one's got adopt I think there's a
difference there I think adopt is your
school board's going to come up with a
policy and they're going to vote on it
and they're going to to adopt it enact
is kind of like Implement I'm sorry
where's the word enact where are you
looking in that 131 says enact and 781
says adopt but is it look at the let's
look at the language if we may so I'm
sorry I'm being a little dense here but
can you help what line is the word does
the word inact appear sorry it's it's at
the top where it says an act I'm
under right here that's just the title
Ole that's just a title that has no I
understand the title but I'm looking at
the they have different it's a syn
it's it's almost a synonym of the word
adopt because if you you're adopting
you're enacting if you're enacting
you're
adopting implementing on the other hand
means that you must execute exactly you
you you you can develop something you
can adopt something but then you need to
implement it okay exactly or execute at
some point in time the 60 days what I
was saying is they both say okay they're
both language so you believe that the
that line nine and line 13 in each of
the bills is indicative that
well in 131 it says 60 days in 781 it
says July 1st 2025 Y which means that
upon it upon um enactment by the general
court and and a signature of the
governor that either 60 days or July 1
2025 depending on which of these might
make it through that that the school
boards have to do this in in the next
three or four months is that
realistic I'm saying I don't think
adopting means that they have to it says
they have to adopt a policy okay so then
the the ACT shall take effect in the
sense that the directive being given to
the school boards is either 60 days
after Passage they have to know by 60
days after passage or by July 1 2025
they have to be
informed that they now have to do thus
and
so I'm just trying to be be clear
about whether or not that is the
understanding that we have and whether
that would carry the
time because now we have two questions
before us in my way of thinking develop
and adopt and
Implement means that you're executing on
what you've
adopted you adopt something then you're
bound to do something about it you may
not necessarily have to say execute or
implement but it makes it abundantly
clear that that's what has to happen
then we have the issue of well when does
it take
effect when does the clock start
what what are your
thoughts whether whether the word
implement or uh execute appears in in
the language we still have developed an
adopt that we haven't disagreed on it's
it's there in both of these
bills and the clock starts 60 days or
2025 and that means what that that's
when the school boards have to start
acting upon the law or that they
actually have to develop and adopt by
those dates I say the acting upon the
law
is is develop and adopting the policy
you were on the school board you could
right I mean you adopt a policy and you
when you adopt a policy I would think
you decide when is going to take effect
when are you going to implement this
policy we're I I think we're telling now
well but also if it's something that
came down from the state they would
determine when we have to have this
implemented by right well do we want to
leave this to Ru making or do we want to
actually put into the language of the
bill when the school board shall develop
and adopt a policy no later than such
and such a date all right and the ACT
takes effect July 1st 2025 or 60 days
after
passage excuse
me I'm almost better so um so the the
dates are not necessarily the same the
law goes into effect in SE July 1st 2025
or 60 days after passage either one of
those unless we come up with something
else but that does not tell the school
boards when what what the deadline is
for them to develop and adopt the policy
that they
develop do we want to see do we want to
see them work working on this for an
indeterminate period of time or a
determinate period determined period of
time is your definition of working on it
to adopt a policy no no I mean no no you
can you you could a school board could
assign a work group to work on adopt on
developing the policy for that school
district with an eye to adopting it if
it receives majority the support if I'm
appointed as a school board member to
work on that sub subcommittee one of my
first questions is going to be well when
do I have to do when does this have to
be
done I would think this date at the end
is what we're do we want it
right no what I see is that the ACT
shall take effect in other words if if
if either of these bills let's just say
that that we don't make any changes I
know what you're saying if either of
these bills are adopted that means that
becomes the that's when the clock starts
in terms of the requirement being placed
upon the school boards but it doesn't
tell them how long they have to develop
and adopt okay so we're so are we clear
on my we're clear am I being clear
you're clear so I think no matter what
we care yes so I think no matter what we
we're going to need these to amend these
spills with the date assuming that the
governor had mentioned that it she had
wanted it in the budget right if the
budget were to pass when would that
exactly go into effect is that the
following
July January the following
July when would this money be available
so uh if if there was any money if there
were to be so the budget is for fiscal
year 2026 isn't it we're still in the
current year and we've got four months
to
go therefore the money would be
available later this year into early
next
year so I my thought we already are
operating under the under the the
current budget the current budget year
expires I believe at the end of June if
that's the case we we have to adopt a
budget for fiscal year 2026 beginning
July
1 all right so that's the the answer to
your question if the money is in the in
in the governor's proposed budget the
money is there if it survives right yeah
then that money would be available in
the next fiscal year which would be the
next school year because the two run
somewhat concurrently yes I'm going to
say I mean I really don't think we are
ready to do anything with money I I
think we're at a point right now that we
should be just talking about what is it
that we want school boards to do we
don't have enough money there's not
enough money even with the 250,000 you
know you're going to start this grant
program the doe doesn't know what
they're doing I think it's way premature
to be talking about money I think we
should ask them to start addressing the
problem the problem is we need to we
need them to have a cell phone and
personal communication device policy and
then from there year two you know I mean
we're not adverse to um it's just
premature won't school boards do what
they can do within their means if there
is to be any money spent my my my my uh
older
son's school district is Franklin
Massachusetts is two teen I have two
teen Grandsons in the Franklin
Massachusetts school district I realize
we can start tossing around school
districts Here There and Everywhere but
that District has adopted a full day ban
on Cell phon smart watches and tablets
because they believe that they are doing
great damage to the children
particularly in the learning environment
during the time in which they're of
course in which they're in
school there are no
pouches and to the best of my knowledge
from my conversation with him there's no
State money coming from the state of
Massachusetts in order to implement the
band because if you enact a pull ban you
don't have to have any pouches anyway or
what they're whatever they were called I
can't remember Yonder or something yeah
whatever so also we have seen with
respect as I've read the literature with
respect to what's going on in the states
I the the specifics are all across the
board but there are states that have
adopted laws that require their local
school boards to develop and adopt
policies
period that's it and they have not
provided any
funding or laid on any other specifics
as to any
restrictions
or uh
exceptions so it's wide open we can look
with an eye to what is being done in
other states for our information and
hopefully for our benefit as we look at
all of those but uh um at the very
least it it seems to me that we want to
at least get the ball rolling here and
make sure that we have that that our
school districts know that in order for
our kids to
have to use the word adequate an
adequate and appropriate education that
involves the learning environment and
the learning environment must be
free of unre restricted cell phone usage
during school hours so school districts
have got to do something some as my I
understand and and representative L
maybe you you know more about this than
I do um I understand that some have
adopted policies others have not correct
I know that for example in in Alton
Prospect Mountain has adopted um a
policy I think that if we if if we pass
either of these two bills or something
on the order of of it even without
money the school boards Association is
going to jump in and they're going to
start developing model policies for
their school boards to look at and I
hope it would be at least one or
more unless we believe that we need to
place
restrictions in the legislation that
would therefore inform the school boards
Association or the school boards well we
can adopt and Implement develop adop and
Implement policies but uh they can't go
any further than this or they have to
include at least this right I right I
personally think that we've kind of hit
a point where we're kind of boiling over
at this point we haven't handled this
for years we probably should even at the
parental level maybe we should have
handled it at the educational level but
I feel as though the educators are
screaming and saying please we really
need your help on this will you guide us
so I personally feel that yes we do need
something to be put in um minimum
standards and for me personally that
could be as simple as it it I don't
necessarily feel strongly about Bell to
Bell you know fine let them have it at
lunch or or study hall or or what have
you if if we want to be a little bit
more lenient but I definitely think that
the schools need some type of guidance
and I think they do want to be able to
say that it's on the state at this point
in time they're they're looking to us
right now so there are two sentences
following
which which indicate that districts are
encouraged to consider exceptions to
student use during instruction when an
educator is using devices as part of a
lesson plan right did you that sentence
should be gone yeah uh explain um or
speak to that please oh sure
um because I'm hearing that there are
teachers a minority but you know all you
have to do is have one drunk driver on
the road too right uh that there are
teachers that are are are giving
students assignments and then they're on
their cell phones during class time
while the students are being given their
assignments that may or may involve
their cell phones so if we if we don't
do this what we're saying is that the
school boards have to deal with that
issue because all we're telling them to
do absent that sentence in it which
appears in both the bills is that they
have to they have to come up with a
policy and then it's up to them to
develop what restrictions they're going
to place or what permiss they're going
to give correct are are you talking
about the instructors right now or the
ca um the policy is what
would that may provide exceptions to
student use during instruction when the
educator is using devices as part of a
lesson plan right that if that language
is retained then that language must be
implemented if the bill passes and is
enacted into law so whatever policies
the school boards come up with it would
have to reflect faithfulness to this
requirement yeah we heard all from the
testimony we heard from you know
teachers unions from teach teachers
whatever all those everyone in the room
really is that this was not a good idea
um and you could have a first of all in
most classrooms they have Chromebooks so
the fact that are these teachers really
using their they having the kids use
their cell phones for something that
can't be done on the device that's that
can be
monitored by the school right I.E their
Chromebooks um the other thing you could
have is teacher against teacher you know
just oh it's okay just use your cellone
that that's problematic in and of itself
um so I personally don't think that
Senate should be there the language is
districts are encouraged to
consider but the districts are not
required I understand that right so this
is a May versus a shell broadly speaking
what we're saying is that we would like
that we would like school districts who
consider as part of their
policies making except I to student use
during instruction when an educator is
using devices as part of a lesson plan
but we're not requiring that but unless
we take it away in which we have said
absolutely nothing about it right so if
we take it right if we take it away they
still can consider the The Only
Exception if we take that away the only
exception is hey if the kid has an IEP
has a 504 elll Learners um medical now
we're saying You must consider those
exceptions well sentence is it the third
we do in fact say that school district
policiy shall not prohibit students with
disabilities from using a device to
support their learning as identified by
the IEP or 504 plan that's right and
that's what we those are special cases
and we're saying there's no negotiation
on that that that must be part of the of
the policy that the school board is is
going to adopt right are are you not
comfortable with the wording that I had
handed out because I feel like it
handles some of that such policy shall
prohibit personal device use by students
during the school day so they can use
School issued Chromebooks right um and
then School District policy shall not
prohibit students with disabilities from
using a device and that includes 504 and
IEP um it also includes um the Civil
Rights Act of 1964 I feel like that's a
comprehensive do you not is elll in
please students with so no would we
consider medical different from
disabilities then I just want to clarify
yeah yeah because medical if you go back
to the other if we go to um is it 381
what are we looking at here
um one
okay what's interesting I went back
through the policies from you've gone
through them extensively to having from
the other states and I've noticed that
epilepsy and diabetes were specifically
singled out I think those are the only
two medical disorders that I I'm not
sure rather than specify medical
disorders could we not say something on
the order of I mean just we're just
brainstorming here of course yeah
something on the order of uh medical
issues as certified by a licensed
physician all right I so so or or do we
want to start determining what those
conditions are that have to be validated
I make a suggestion yes okay my
suggestion would be school district
policy shall not prohibit students with
disabilities from using a device to
support their learning as identified by
their IEPs of five or4 that's in there
right now exceptions may also include
the use of devices to manage students
health care for example glue coose
sensors or insulin pumps just examples
or to support English language Learners
so now you you're you're including elll
and what was your broad category before
you got to your EG manage students
Health Care devices use of devices to
manage students healthare all right well
how is Healthcare how is English as a
second language a health issue no it's
not that's what it says okay where where
did the parentheses in for the EG oh
after the insulin pumps oh okay well so
I so that's so so that that's medical
and then you go on to yes to the Engish
so not seeing it was yeah I understand
that right we don't usually I I
personally to be honest I know we're
really getting into the weeds here but
um I I would personally like to see some
type of language where it's specific to
they absolutely need this device for
monitoring because I don't want us to go
down the rabbit hole of my child is
anxious if they don't have the phone
near them I mean this is a diagnosis
it's psychiatric they suffer from
anxiety they need to have it with them
physician certified medical
issues what what if it's a psychiatrist
what if it's a
psychologist Medical
Professional certified that's a good I I
I would personally be more comfortable
if we were specific and not put the
schools in this position of of managing
Healthcare you think are you concerned
with just managing healthare I mean I I
looked at a lot of policies nowhere that
I see and maybe you guys did see and I I
always saw something along the lines of
managing Healthcare and most of them
specified insulin pumps most of them and
sense so
mentally uh
managing health and mental
health no I or just say health
and that covers
everything you you make a good point
like holy smokes someone said on my
kidneys a phone to the whole this is the
whole point well the problem here is
when we start making these
exceptions eventually it might lead to
uh it being so broad that you can drive
a truck through it right I I I'm just
saying that I've seen other states
actually specify yes the disorders that
they are using well legislators have a
tendency to get
but if you want to I mean I would say if
you have specific somewhere I mean I
believe Virginia does i i the ones I
look at they mentioned the pumps and the
um how did you feel about that like I
liked that oh I'm good I mean if they
need their if they need the device to
test the sugar or whatever they're doing
did you so the school boards need to
adopt policies governing cell student
cell phone use in
schools but they
must adopt policies that include these
exceptions yeah and that's why I think
now now now we have to come up with
we've already got districts are you wna
you're suggesting we get rid of
districts are encouraged to consider
exceptions to student use during
instruction when an educator is using
devices as part of a lesson plan let
Mista yeah I don't like that you don't
like that I don't think they need it as
part of a lesson plan I No in fact I
don't know I listened to this this this
English woman I mean the article that
got sent around and I mean I looked at
and I mean I when she was finished I
didn't even realize the 20 minutes had
passed uh no ums no huz um marvelous
articulation incredible knowledge uh doc
well
documented and you want to talk about
radical go to the root of well she she's
she want she would just rather to ban
them entire because they're destroying
our children my opthalmologist and
optometrist confirms that that
children's eyesight is being ruined at
an early age I was one of those
unfortunate few who had to get glasses
in the fourth grade uh in my family I
didn't realize at the time I was only
fourth grade but I I had to get glasses
for shortsightedness at which point it
wasn't as bad as bullying but I used to
take a lot of harassment for being
called four eyes and everything else but
but this is now becoming this is she
said this is going to be within a few
years unless there this is my automet
now saying this unless we do something
as a
society almost every child is going to
be wearing
glasses right and that's just glasses
that's just eyesight that's not even
what's happening to their brain exactly
I we need to get a handle on us you're
talking about that we we're talking
about the kids have full access to a a
world of things they shouldn't for
example pornography they don't need to
have access to that certainly not in
school not at all but certainly not in
school right exactly I I think we have
to be bold on this it's that important
and it and it's getting that late in the
game so get are you agreeing get rid of
that sentence yeah yeah but I do I don't
agree with um I know I don't know about
during this work session but in general
some people have talked about the
teachers not having their cell phones I
don't personally I feel like that's kind
of an employer employee relationship and
let the super tenant and the principal I
think deal with that at that level if it
becomes an issue I I would prefer to see
us just dealing with the student
body and that I mean it says governing
student cell phone use so the teacher
not really part of it but
um representative Terry do you agree
that we should get rid of that sentence
District I'm fine with getting rid of
that sentence I am too all right so we
need to take a formal action with
respect to recommendation
and Melissa because I'm a man and I
don't multitask as well as women and my
wife will tell you that that is
not that is a personal
observation she has picked up somewhere
along the line if you would note that in
your notes and send that to me that will
be very helpful to me in terms of
filling out the subcommittee report and
then uh submitting that to Chairman
cordelli so what we're talking about is
with respect to both bills we are
eliminating the sentence that
coincidentally in both
bills um begins on line five and ends on
line six right the sentence districts
are encouraged ending with the words as
part of a lesson land plan beginning on
line five and line six with respect to
both both bills we're eliminating it in
both bills not just one but both am I
hearing us yes all right um um I need a
motion I make a motion you may need a
motion to remove that sentence I make a
motion that the sentence districts are
encouraged to consider exceptions um to
student use during instruction when an
educator using devices as part of a
lesson plan that that be struck from the
lines five and six sorry in both bills
correct is there a second I'll second
all right any further
discussion no with will the clerk Pro
call the
role yes um representative wall say wall
wall hi representative Hall it's 11:40
wall did she say wall representative
litfield
yes and um chairman Terry yes thank you
all
right all right um returning to the the
the the sentence School District
policies shall include shall not
prohibit student with disabilities that
sentence appears in both bills I mean
this actually become is a little is our
friend because it's in both bills so if
we're going to make any changes we may
as well as with the previous amend that
we have adopted uh it's going to pertain
to both the bills and Melissa you have
pointed to the language that you took
from the governor's budget
proposal and representative Hall you
felt it was import I heard you say it
was important that we
include
medical um issues as well as elll
learners ELO support ELO Learners all
right
so is there a preference for retaining
the language in the bills as
introduced is there a preference for
changing
it let's just start with that question
does does do either of you want to just
go with the language that's in the
bills you do no are you saying end it
with 504 and not have the medical and
not have the ell do either of you want
to retain this language period that's it
without any change without any changes
but can we add a sentence after you well
we're going to get to that next because
because we're GNA say that we we don't
want this any longer as is so it's you
you do not you're not happy with that
sentence it does it's not inclusive
enough fine correct
representative
meliss yes I agree that it should be I
agree so we're going to do something now
about the the third or what it is the
fourth s the last sentence okay we're
now we have the language from the
proposal
but we may as well open the whole can
here this Lang excuse me the first
sentence in the governor's
proposed language is identical to what
sentence instead of utilizing the word
restrict the word
prohibit is
used
correct such policy shall prohibit
personal device used by students during
the school day and be implemented
schoolwide with approved exceptions
determined by
student medical disability or language
proficiency needs which I think captures
or expresses the concerns representative
ago however there's
another bombshell in here because we're
now prohibiting rather than restricting
and we're prohibiting it during the
school day rather than just
during class
instruction where are we at right now
what line what number I'm sorry if
you're looking at um I got this all
right so if you look if you look at the
second
sentence such policy shall prohibit
personal device shall prohibit not
restrict restrict as in the bills
prohibit personal device used by
students during the school day and be
implemented
schoolwide with approved exception
determined that is the policy with
approved exceptions determined by
student medical disability or language
proficiency
needs such policy shall be developed in
collabor okay so how are how are you
with that sentence the first key
difference is prohibit rather than
restrict I I love the sentence I think I
would prefer to see the word
restrict versus prohibit but the rest of
the sentence I like it how do you feel
about that um I
think that now you're saying it must be
now you're not you're taking away local
control right now now you're saying
you're restricting cell phone or
prohibiting during the school day I mean
in essence that's what we're talking
about
but like some like different policies we
look at some of them were for this
school but not that school some of them
were you know the older kids could have
it during lunch but not this is saying
here you're prohibiting it during the
school day this means Bell to Bell right
in the bills the the prohibition or the
Restriction is during class instruction
only right all
right it doesn't say encourage it says
such policy shall restrict the use of
student personal cell phones during
class instruction without educator
approval right now the exception are
further down in the paragraph however
you're correct in in the governor's
proposed
language the policy is during the entire
school day and schoolwide it is far more
restrictive and it is is far more
directive as to what the policy must
say we're basically if if we were to
adopt that sentence that language we
would be saying that all school
districts throughout the state have to
adopt a policy that is schoolwide during
the entire school day B to Bell yep I
don't think I how do you feel about that
and milissa how do you feel about that I
think it should be local control let let
the local people decide how they're
going to handle it
and yeah that's
that so I I personally think think it
should just be at a minimum if we want
to have local control sure but I think
at a minimum it should be we're saying
top down during class time no cell
phones they've had ample opportunity in
many years with local control to curb
this and it hasn't
happened
so what I'm hearing is that at the very
minimum we want to see that classroom
usage
is being addressed and restricted
without directing school boards to tell
to include other portions of the school
day that's up to them what they do we're
not telling them that they can't make it
schoolwide and during the entire school
day but they must at
least they must at least restrict the
usage during classroom
time and representative Hall I heard you
say yeah I it tell me for yeah because
there should be local control as to
whether it's extended beyond the
classroom but did you AG agree with
restrictions with respect to classroom
usage and I heard you say the same
representative Lichfield am I
correct uh maybe not hold on one second
yeah now remember we're going to get
into exceptions later on because we're
going to deal we're going to get into uh
uh exceptions for
individualized plans
504s uh English as a as a second
language
and yeah I um medic no we don't need to
okay
with the governor's Medical
with if we if if we if we don't in the
governor's proposed language if we don't
go with prohibit we go with restrict
let's just say for the moment all right
and we don't go with use by students
during the school day and be implemented
school whyde we could pick up the last
part of that sentence and add it to the
second to the second sentence that
already exists in the bill let me read
it if you refer to the bill either one
such policy shall restrict the use of
students personal cell phone use during
class instruction without educator
approval and with approved exceptions
determined by student medical disability
or language proficiency
needs I kind I back up for a minute that
sentence on on the two bills not the
governor's sentence such policy shall
restrict the use of student personal
cell phones during class instruction
without educator approval that was also
one that we talked about getting rid of
that well wait wait I'm sorry we we uh
we we just got rid of that yeah we voted
to get rid of it well we voted to get
rid of recommend getting rid of the both
sentences two sentences there I'm sorry
I didn't mean to do that we I believe it
I if no the third yeah what I had what I
had written down and I may have been
incorrect I wrote down that we would
take out districts are encouraged to
consider we didn't get rid of the second
S no I I would I would say in my opinion
um I like what you're saying you can do
a cut and pay yeah let's just remove the
without educator
approval such policy shall restrict the
use of student personal cell phones
during class
instructed with approved exceptions
determined by student medical disability
nice um I have to think on that one a
minute because I I know do we really
want cell phones being utilized in our
classes do we you know uh this there is
no demonstrated over
compelling benefit to students using
cell phones as a matter of fact if I'm a
student and I'm sitting in my favorite
row and chair towards the back of the
room where I can get away with most
anything and I'm supposed to be doing
thus and so and instead I'm on a porn
site well we have just provided for that
to occur because if individual Educators
want to utilize cell phones in the
classroom how will the educator
determine whether or not all of the
students are actually complying in
they're on the right website and for me
personally honestly we we talk about um
equality and I personally just look at
cell phones if an instructor is going to
say to the kids use your personal device
I personally feel talk about the Hales
and the Have Nots like there's a
disparity there I just I absolutely
don't agree with it if you want them
using technology then use the school
tech and and and what floes me too
though is we continue to hear well then
the schools have to have a onetoone
device per student really don't actually
for years we had carts with devices and
you bring it into the classroom with
what CS C carts so you could have a no
but seriously you could have a c was a
musical school no I'm dating myself here
but I'm just saying if you really needed
the Chromebooks right you you have a
classroom of 25 or 30 kids then you have
the 30 Chromebooks and they can use it
during that class most Schools are they
are issuing the oneto one at this point
anyway but yeah were you did you just
say just get rid of without educator
approval yeah you say yeah yeah yeah
that's like I mean the rest of that
sentence I mean I think that's really
what this is about isn't it isn't this
about not using cell phones during class
right or
absolutely because then we then go on to
say after sentence one governing cell
student cell phone use such policy shall
restrict the use of student personal
cell phones
during class
instruction all right yes okay comma
with approved exceptions determined by
student medical disability and language
proficiency needs Yes or
No Yes except that is line one
disability or language one two three do
you see the sentence halfway um do you
see the word with in line three four or
five words in yep adopting that language
with u co-opting that to this sentence
with approved exceptions determined by
student medical disability or language
proficiency needs who's
approving well that would be under the
policy
that's a good question but do yeah let's
walk around that because we're saying
they have to have because it say they
shall they shall not prohibit students
with disabilities so I'm not sure who's
approving those exceptions I I would in
in my opinion many of the policies that
I've seen over time were um with the
approval of the superintendent or his
design so if that's the case because the
nurse could be the designate do you know
what I'm saying
specify that who who gives the approval
for the exceptions no I think what if we
didn't have the word approved with
exceptions determined by student I mean
is if the school board is adopting a
policy aren't they the ones that are
going to we're telling them you must
make exceptions for these
people um it's it's the school board's
responsibility to
determine um whether or not the
exceptions are approved or not within
the area of areas of medical disability
or language proficiency
needs is it not their if it's their
policy aren't they the ones who
decide um whether there will be
exceptions based on these three
categories I I just I would get rid of
the word approved but I because I I just
it's GNA bring that question I'm the
parent I could I I could accept that I
could accept
getting yes because it's already the
school board that's adopting the policy
so why do we need it's almost redundant
right implemented School redundant with
exceptions determined by student medical
disability if the word is approved as
unnecessary what I think I think I see
that Melissa you're no it's fine I saw
you I saw you with that that I have this
link you know you know whenever I get
like I'm thinking I had that you're
thinking I do I have all right so I'm
going back to your thinking about the
mental health com they need pH for
um I I don't I don't see that happen
it's a mental health thing that's why
we're doing this to help their mental
health I just want to go in the weed a
little bit further because I'm looking
at policies from other I'm going to get
on my Soap Box a little bit but from
other states and for example a student
who is a member of a volunteer
firefighting organization or emergency
organization maybe authorized to carry a
device aren't they in school to be in
school like I don't understand well as I
indicated earlier legislators love to
legislate I mean it it's almost becomes
a form of Vatican casuistry I mean you
know they have have a word in in a
restriction or whatever cover everything
under the sun right you know or the or
the talet you know everything is
covered I'm prepare I'm ready to ask you
whether you're willing to retain the
language beginning on line four such
policies shall restrict the use of
student personal cell phones during
class
instruction excuse me but
eliminating so therefore we don't need
to take any action but
eliminating the the words without
educator approval placing a comma after
the word instruction at the end of line
four and replacing it with the language
in the governor's proposed language with
approved exceptions we can lift that
with approved exception C determined by
student medical disability or language
I'm sorry with
exceptions with exceptions
determined by student medical disability
or language proficiency needs and we we
just lift that language we steal it we
put it in
here all right so we will need a motion
to the
effect that the last three
words in the sentence
that begins on line
four be
struck the sentence that begins on line
four okay the last three
words shall be struck and replaced
with quote with exceptions determined by
student medical disability or language
quote Yeah I'm just going back to were
approve for a second well you want to
get rid of it have you changed your mind
well I'm I'm I'm asking question you
have that you have that prerogative no
I'm just wondering is this let's
say I've got a kid in my
class is this I'm I'm actually wondering
why the word approve was there I'm just
wondering
why my gut tells me it didn't need to be
there but is there a
situation where well what's the opposite
of appr approved unapproved can you have
a disapproved
exception how can you not have an
exception unless it's approved I I
personally don't disagree with having
approved I just think that you need to
put approved by whom and that's why I we
we we have have yeah yeah you're you're
you're actually prompted to have to do
something with approved by yeah that
that's the whole you keep if you retain
approved if you take it away you don't
have to do that okay let's take it away
I'm good so do you need a motion
did you get did you get what I said I do
but did that give the parents the power
to push the except I'm I personally I
honestly would say superintendent or his
Des me I I don't or whatever the word is
know with the approved exceptions
granted by the superintendent or his if
we
said yeah is or her designate that could
be the school nurse it could be the
school principal right so do you know
what I'm saying because you yeah because
you might have an assistant
superintendent and and that's the
responsibility of the so are you okay
with approved retaining approved by the
designate a problem have to be I don't
have a problem with the idea um I'm just
wondering so you're in a class and the
kids got
a got the cell phone I need it I've got
a thing they don't show it to me
do I have to
get I have to contact somebody and say
you know oh wait minut you can't use
that phone I guess I'm just thinking the
process like who's gonna well who's
going to police a disability is GNA is a
disability only going to be for a day
right is a language proficiency issue
going to be only for a day no is a
medical issue exactly going to be
longterm or could it also be shortterm
and then you got to to get the
superintendent or his
Design's approval in order to have a
medical exception for somebody with a
need and is that is that a big deal it's
not a big deal they do it all the time
so approved by superintendent or his or
his or her designate yeah right did you
got that yeah I already workot it okay
approved by so because originally when I
spoke I I didn't include the word
approved so now we got approved with
exception with approved
by the
superintendent or his or her
designate
uh determined that's a long sentence oh
okay yeah actually let's yeah because I
and then you don't want to use by again
you want to say with respect to student
medical disability or language
proficiency with respect to okay so
where is the originally bu so we have
comma with approved exceptions
determined
by the
superintendent or his or her
designate based
on with respect to
medical disability or language
proficiency
needs to students with respect to
students medical students student okay
medical disability or language
proficiency
needs
okay I'm gonna have to go type all this
as soon as we get back okay uh we need
consensus on this no all right yeah a
motion
you got you you the chair typically
doesn't make motions in my world so yeah
you got who wants to go who wants to
make the motion you wanna you want to
it's your turn Melissa you want to do
that okay and then rep you got a
second okay is is our motion our motion
is
twofold and that is well in two parts
we're Parts we're eliminating okay the
words at the end of this first of the
sentence beginning on line four and
ending on line five that is without
educator approval right and we are
inserting okay so we are looking at the
bills in front of us right now and
beginning on line four such policy shall
restrict the use of student personal
cell phones during class instruction we
are going to keep that we are going to
remove the three words without educator
educator Comm put a comma and insert the
words and then we're going to insert the
words um with approved with approved ex
exceptions by the
superintendent determined by determined
by with approved exceptions determined
by okay determined by
by super superintendent or his her
design with respect to student medical
disability or language proficiency needs
perfect long sentence I think you just
made the motion perfect oh I have to
again I'll second it right now to put
that in langage uh anything more to be
said we're basically doing one sentence
every half hour here I know all in favor
uh would you call the role please yes
yes representative Hall yes
representative witfield is yes and
okay we've already gotten rid of the
third sentence Oh by and would you also
uh could we agree by consensus that that
that that that motion is with respect to
both
bills yeah all right with respect to
both bills HB 781 FM and HB 131 okay ask
a question about procedure so is it our
role to come up with an amendment our
role okay let's say we come up with an
amendment then it goes to the committee
right and then the
committee the
committee discusses the amendment and
then we vote on the amendment and
someone can amend the amendment if they
wanted to is that correct
so what we can do here is we can make
recommendations to the full committee
okay those recommendations can just be
recommendations or they can be formally
offered as amendments an amendment okay
and when we make the recommendations
we're making
recommendations as amendments then
formally somebody would have to draft
draft the amendment and put his or her
name on it okay right that sounds good
that in a more formal sense
uh you would we we could vote to adopt
amendment number but we're not okay
we're nowhere near having an adopted an
amendment number assigned yet all
right um
now I believe what we have is
Schoolboard shall develop and adopt a
policy governing student cell phone use
in schools such policy shall restrict
the use of student personnel personal
cell phones during class
instruction
comma with exceptions determined by the
superintendent and his or her
designate with respect to student
medical disability or language
proficiency needs can I make a
suggestion and if it's well let me just
conclude by saying if in
fact if in fact that we do that
then we need to look at whether we need
to
actually
um we can retain the language that
school district's policy shall not
prohibit students with disabilities from
using a device to support their learning
we can go so far as to say that in
addition to as identified by their
IEPs plan developed under Section 504
blah blah blah blah blah or when
required to support emergent
multilingual students with appropriate
language access programs and services
pursuing to title six of the Civil
Rights Acts of 1964 that language could
be could could be uh inserted in both
bills okay and that does not change
anything that we've
already decided here to recommend okay
agree um if we could go back and just
make that sentence which sentence the
the big long one that we just we just
approved yes can make that two sentences
saying the exact same thing you know
just exceptions may I I can't see it in
front of me right now but no content is
changed on well the way to do that is to
say such policy shall restrict the use
of student Personnel cell phones during
class
instruction period y
exceptions may be
determined by the superintendent and his
or her
design with respect to student with
respect to student medical disability or
language proficiency needs that that
makes it two sent we got careful with
the May it's not a bad sentence when you
look at it in when you look at it can I
just show it to her yes isn't this why
we have lawyers let me see yeah and I
like that there too in Cas can you live
with that oh up here I'm not okay wait
I know I went to school where you were
supposed to use a lot of just imp
imperative sentences and not have a lot
and the other way you could do it end it
right here and say approved exceptions
shall be determined by the blah blah
blah BL but leave it like that for now
somebody in the other room can decide
any approved exceptions do do you want
to do you want well let's do as much as
we can here do we want two sentences or
one you think the sent look long that's
your shall restrict the use of student
personal cell phones during class
instruction comma with the approved
exceptions determined by the
superintendent his or her design with
respect to student medical disability or
Lang it looks good that doesn't look too
excessive for me in my in my world and
I'm the queen of commas and
short the first part I think you have
one word too many there restrict the use
of student personal cell phones during
CL instruction are we I just as I think
about that are we telling the school
districts
um you need to focus on classroom
instruction because really what we're
we're hoping they're going to do more
than that right um but by saying you
shall do this are we letting them know
Well you want to insert the words such
policy shall restrict the use of student
Personnel cell phones at least during
class
instruction remember we didn't want to
go school wide in school whole school
day let's leave it yeah um let's leave
it like it is for right now I'm going to
say I mean you are sending a message
least but if you're saying you shall
you're also sending the message they're
not going to be used during class so I
think I'm okay with the way that is and
I'm thinking other schools may say no
you can't do it during lunch because
some of those policies we looked at the
high school kids could use them during
lunch but the middle schoolers couldn't
in the same district so we do want to
give them some leeway and what they're
doing well and we do that with the word
Shell at least but we don't have to have
at least I think I think leave it as it
all right I can live with
that do do you think that school boards
might misread this and think that we're
telling them that we want them to
restrict the use of cell phones by
students only during the school
instruction time I'd have to I'd have to
see the whole thing when we have the
whole thing drafted get one more look at
it in writing and to see how I would
interpret that I'm
not um because we are saying minimally
you that I think that's the message
we're giving you minimally they can't be
used during class time right is that the
message we're
giving right like well I forget what's
written that so I mean that's what it
says it it doesn't it doesn't the
language of the first two sentences does
does not prohibit further restrictions
right but it could be
read and interpreted as this is what
they this is all that they mean they
only want us to do this for school
instruction or they're only requiring us
to do it for school in instruction and
they really don't want us to do anything
and we don't want to touch it with a
10-foot pole the state is that's what
the state is saying but if you say at
least then you're hinting that this is
the minimal standard that must be
adopted in the
policy correct I don't I'm not asking
you to approve that but that that that
is a correct analysis isn't it at least
and and then it and then it becomes hint
hint
suggestive you you know you you should
be doing more than this have you ever
seen an RSA with the words at least
that's why I take I haven't I'm and it
could exist I'm just throwing it out
there I think we're okay with the way it
is they shall like Clash instruction
when I'm thinking about we here in
another year or two if if we're still
here that um we got problems because the
policies only pertain to CL usage and we
got terrible stuff going on in the
lunchrooms and the school board didn't
see fit to put that and then they blame
us because we didn't put it in the
language of the
RSA then we go back and say okay well we
fix that now
we'll say playground in school lunch
period or whatever we want to do this is
nothing that says that we
can't run it by anybody else who run
what by them well I don't know like I
would love to run some of this by
attorney Fenton to be like you know is
she's seen that type of working before
it does it make sense well you could put
at least in and then just strike it okay
the committee could then strike it I I
don't think we should you want to have
do we want to have a discussion at the
committee level as to whether we insert
the words at least or do you want to
have a discussion at the committee level
as to whether or not we we we strike the
words at least I would say go in without
words at
least and just I have that discussion
those are kind of we are opening a can
of worms then because then if anybody
raises that question then then we have
to start talking about at least or what
what other you know similar language
it's EAS to my way of think it's easier
to strike words than it is to insert
them they still you know this is not
your you know your final vote I know
that how about it
brainstorming um such a policy shall
restrict the use of student personal
cell phones during class
instruction and we throw out something
like and other times is deemed
appropriate
by I don't know if we say the
administration or whatever but should
we well now now we're going to have to
have two sentences because if we start
adding
on I asking now you got a runaway train
here but I think you know if the three
of us can agree on content on on intent
yes right I mean that's a huge thing
that's and I think we are agreeing on
intent well that that's a big part of
our task and that's why I'm thinking I
mean that's what the chair is yeah
hoping and Desiring comes out of this so
I mean the same P this is viewed this is
viewed as being a
consensus
issue and and and not not
partisan uh um we all recognize this is
a huge problem and we need to do
something so if we come out of here with
recommendations that potentially should
carry a lot of weight with the rest of
the
committee and that's that's the thinking
here put the three best brains on the
committee in this room to see what can
come
up all right are you
laughing I think um I didn't even know
you guys are there so so let go back to
way back there's laughing gas in the
back of the room it's coming out of the
way back when we talked about oh I hope
we don't have to go back and do things
we already we do well when we say during
class instruction me mean we're we're
setting them up and that's why I said
initially if you got rid of that
sentence it would be such policy shall
restrict the use of students personal
cell phones
period okay
and then the exception then the
exception I mean well yes because then
what you're doing is you're throwing the
door open to you're saying you you got
to come up with when you're going to do
this and where and you know there's not
a district that's not going to start
with classroom instruction there's not a
one that that that's that that that
appears to make a lot of sense to me
Melissa does that to you not
yet can you repeat that such policy
shall restrict the use of student
Personnel cell
phones during school time MH during
school it just said cell phone use in
schools it just said that so okay so we
don't need to do that such policy shall
restrict the use of student personal
personal cell phones in school okay in
schools and then um well we don't need
to say we don't need the sentence at all
right the whole sentence well what about
W with approved exceptions determined by
student Medical well that has to happen
but let's say if you got rid of like I
said first I don't know why I went back
well well first of all the word
governing appears in the
first then the word restrict appears in
sentence
two there's a difference between
governing and
restricting you can be very permissive
in your
restricting School Board shall develop
and adopt a policy restricting student
cell phone use in schools then it goes
right down
to the school district policy shall not
prohibit no no sorry up above here
um what was the next sentence we had
Melissa such policy shall be developed
in no no school district policy shall
not prohibit students with disabilities
so we go right from there like you got
to develop a policy and then you go
right into these are the exceptions that
you need do you know what's interesting
is consistently both the two bills and
the governor's wording all have a policy
governing they all have that wording
well that's because we're the government
we like the government just
initially can we can we ask these folks
if there's a difference between restri
governing you you could have both words
governing and
restricting can I ask a question I'm
just curious yes do you guys have a
difference between governing and
restricting if I said School Board shall
develop and adopt a policy governing
student cell phone use or restricting
would that be inclusive of restrictive
but not think a
rest is
part
think
yes could governance you can p out yes
that's
right governance is this restriction is
this restriction is a subset of
governing but our following sentence
says the word sh say it states shall
restrict well if you retain governing in
the first sentence and then you put
restriction in sentence two then the
governance must include that
restriction okay that works isn't it so
well do we still have during class
instruction or do we we going to take
that away I say take it away I make a
motion that we take away during class
instruction because that way it opens it
up we know they're going to do it during
class because they can do that and they
they can do even more like my my my
grandson's school district and mass that
said goodbye that no cell phones
anywhere on the school grounds the whole
day okay and they have high proficiency
scores by the way but who knows causal
relationship contributing
all right right but we weren't even
comfortable we removed the wording where
um we had use um during instruction when
an educator is using devices as part of
a lesson plan we took that away we took
that away but my point is
so now we're going to get even I feel as
though we're getting looser by taking
away during class instruction I think
we're getting
stronger I'm not seeing it the reason
thinking that if you have a cell phone
policy okay on the school board the very
first thing you're going to do is you're
going to you're going to address class
time that there's no way you're gonna
say you can't have them at lunch you
class do do you do you I don't agree
with that because agree we so I I just
know that for example um we had a
warrant article in our district which is
a very large District at one point
restricting the use of um electronic
devices and the way that that I saw it
implemented was it was lunch in free
time I didn't necessarily see it during
classroom because they may need it
during class time I I am not comfortable
at all with what we're
saying representative Hall I I think
what you're you're you're doing here uh
I I don't mean to be um at all critical
but I I think what you're doing is
you're
assuming that the views that you hold
and that we share with you you are going
to be universally held by those in
positions to restrict cell phone student
cell phone use and I'm wondering if we
want to have an opening that
huge because you're you're not going to
be the Super you're not going to be the
school board of every school district
and neither am I in the state of New
Hampshire where that view would be
honestly if they were to go with a pouch
system I think it would be easier for
them to restrict the cell phone use for
longer periods of time otherwise the
kids need to have access to the magnets
Etc you
know storage them go out and get a grant
and and if they want to do that I
understand there's money for this sort
of thing and so I'm okay I don't
disagree with the sentence such policy
shall restrict the use of student
personal cell phones during class
instruction I agree with that sentence
Did we keep that we kept it we kept it I
had said during class instruction and we
were talking about Shell at least
because we were concerned that it may
yeah well so if this is the first time
in the history of the state of New
Hampshire that the words at least have
included in RSA then we all will become
oford how about a minimum
how about at a minimum at a minimum
sounds higher class yes at a
minimum it it it sounds loftier it's
more uh uh Barrister friendly so let's
go with that yes so suppose you put that
put it for now such
restrictions uh such policy shall
restrict such policy shall at a minimum
or you you you could begin with at a
minimum such policy where I don't where
do you want to put it that was such
policy such policy yes policy shall at a
minimum restrict the use of student
personal cell phone during class
instruction and then with the phrase
that we the Clause that we robbed from
the governor's budget the policy sh at a
minimum restrict is that you want me to
the policy sh at a minimum restrict
restrict the use of okay so you got the
rest of it I do except for I I want to
clarify something please you want to
read the whole sentence and then we can
tell you what we think sure good uh the
policy shall at a minimum resp restrict
the use of student personal cell phones
during class instruction with the
approved exceptions determined by the
superintendent uh not the approved but
with approved not the approved we don't
want to say the approved with approved
exceptions I'm glad that we're reading
this okay with approved exceptions
determined by the superintendent or his/
her design with respect to student
medical disability or language
proficiency needs yes okay
now um are we am I going directly down
to school dist adding in school district
policy shall not prohibit students with
disabilities from using or I know there
was sentence or two before that and I
wasn't sure if I was to use that or not
the okay so the such policy shall be
developed in um collaboration with any
applicable local education striking that
sentence correct yeah strike it okay I'm
sorry which I'm sorry what are we
striking here from the governor's um
under after well why don't we go back to
781 and uh 131 because now now we're
down to the last sentence School
District policy shall not prohib
students or yes or we can go what's in
view on the Blackboard right now is that
sentence or this one from the governor's
proposal Which is far more detailed the
me all right so here's what we're saying
if we retain this language if we retain
this
language then we've already said that
there are approved exceptions by the
school superintendent or his or her
designate
with respect to uh medical disability or
language proficiency needs but then we
are becoming even more but we are
becoming very specific in
saying in case you don't understand this
school district policy shall not
prohibit students with disability so
we've already been identified as as
being um in the category of may have
exceptions you're saying as a broadly
speaking School District policy shall
not prohibit students with disabilities
so do I believe believe that that
creates problems no do I believe do I I
find that to be perfectly fine and and
we could include that uh I would say yes
unless I am shown the light in a
different direction okay so are you okay
with that the first part well the first
sentence on on the governor right the
first sentence um to the last sentence
now I know you are but let to start with
the first sentence um you just ref it's
reference students medical disability
and language proficiency needs yes down
to the last sentence School District
policy shall not prohibit students
there's nothing about medical there um
and I'm wondering if medical you know
what I mean so they that sentence there
elaborates on what is a disability and
what is the language proficiency needs
but it doesn't I think it needs to say
something about medical like just to
give an example like add the um I got it
here somewhere
well are is medical included in the
section 504 of The Rehabilitation Act of
1973 not the not9 USC so you're going to
have to find a way to separate the two
and say this and this but on medical it
could say let me see
um just do an EG for example glucose
sensors or insulin pumps or something
just letting them know what are we
talking about medical needs I mean I
think they I think I heard in that room
our committee that that needed to be
spelled out to give examples so such
District policy shall not prohibit
students with medical needs EG glucose
monitor pumps y do yep and students with
disabilities from using a so you're
you're so we insert
that right School District policy shall
not prohibit students with
medical
needs such as or for example glucose
monitor pumps
whatever what's the other one and and
and monitor and what else did I see here
insulin pumps insulin pumps okay put a
parenthesis around that for example EG
comma insulin pumps or glucose
monitoring devices can we back up excuse
me exactly where does that for example
go okay sorry do you see the governor's
proposed language yeah School District
policy shall not prohibit yeah School
District policy shall not prohibit
needs
parentheses E Period G period
pumps and glucose sensors
glucose sens what are they called
glucose sensors sensors close
or or or with
disabilities I'm using a device to
support their
learning according to this the language
specified in uh Section 504 of The
Rehabilitation Act of
so I I'm just going to read it back um
School District policy shall not
prohibit students with medical needs
parentheses EG insulin pumps and glucose
sensors and parentheses or disabilities
from using a device to support their
learning as identified by their
individualized education plan um plan
developed under Section 504 of The
Rehabilitation Act of 1973 29 USC 794 or
when required to support emergent
multilingual students with appropriate
language access programs and services
pursuant to um Title 9 of the Civil
Rights Act of
1964 that's good you not like
that yeah I I was on the wrong you moved
it down here instead of up there right
that stayed the same up here do you want
to look at it's it's it's it's the it's
the next sentence now yeah yeah and I
was thinking it's be in that let me
okay it's the it's the it's the new
third sentence in the second paragraph
5 okay
so we're approaching Perfection here but
we have to remember that Perfection
should not be the enemy of the almost
perfect I mean with all with the three
of us and all the time we've spent of
course it's close to perfect but can I I
I think we need
to go back go back go back to the very
beginning when we're talking about cell
phones are we okay with adding cell
phones including smart watches including
don't we want to just say personal what
about personal electronic devices
communication devices or personal
electronic devices to which could
include smart you know smart watches
airpods I always say earbuds airpods yes
yeah I mean so I mean I think we need to
include those personal electronic either
communicate do they all are they allun
they don't all communic well can you
have communication there only one oh yes
them so what's the phrase that captures
devices perfect because personal
electronic
devices yeah oh I like that electronic
communication devices communicating
that's the whole right that's what other
policies had I I didn't make this up I
actually saw it in other policies that
well I've seen that too yeah it madees
sense to me and and quite honestly I
would say that I would anticipate that
that would come up in the committee if
we don't deal with this right now so if
we go back to the first
sentence in section five such P such
School Board shall develop and adopt a
policy governing student cell phone or
do we just want to say and personal can
cell phone
and I've got such policy may also
include okay so let's go school board BL
blah sh development policy governing
access okay in schools such policy may
also include the use of other personal
electronic communication devices such as
airpods I mean do we want to specify
smart watches an airpod or just leave it
why why do we need to don't they already
know what personal Comm communication
devices no they don't know glass no they
don't
know have you identified those in your
so I I like the idea of if we actually
say student cell phone and then we say
other or have
including including personal electronic
and other why don't we just say cell
phones and other personal electronic
communication
devices I'm
getting like which may
include that's right exactly that's
right exactly okay that's right can you
imagine what something's going to be
called two or three years from there and
then they're going to say well they it's
like the the bill that wanted the the
book had to be on a flash drive what who
uses flash drive or you know you have to
watch a certain
book okay can we pause for one moment
please so um this is going to did we
adopt the did we did we finally adopt
this did we have a vote on the second
one not yet Amendment you mean the big
sentence yes no we didn't can we hold
back because I I don't want to get too
far ahead here we're ready to go with
this but we have to take care of the
other the previous why don't may I make
a suggestion um although going to need
help with this wording it's it's
literally a paragraph do you want to
just take a vote on the whole thing
versus sentence by
sentence because we've done this peace
meal this is a good question in in my
humble opinion uh this is a good
question so when we when we fix this
last
sentence which is the first sentence
actually because we're going to put
other electronic devices then what we
can do is we can make a
recommendation that the previous
three uh that that this replaced the
previous three so we don't actually have
to report the previous three because
we're going to have a an entirely new
paragraph consisting of the three
sentences now we've done this one at a
time but yes having effectively dealt
with that
paragraph Roman five
we
can we can do a replace remove and
replace and once we take care of voting
on the
second recommendation and then
apparently a third recommendation that
has just appeared at the 11th hour and
that is that we say cell
phone and other personal electronic
communication
devices but let's get let's let's take
one and then we'll take do the next one
by the way we got about 15 minutes here
before EXA one um can I ask are we going
to our recommendation would that this
should be public schools and Charter
Public Charter Schools we can deal with
that we can deal with that as as
separate and yes we can do that okay all
right so but we're in agreement with
that that's what I want to know yes okay
okay so School Board sh I want to run
the sense by yes that's what has to
happen next please okay School Board
shall develop and adopt a policy
governing student cell phone use and
personal electronic communication
devices in schools all right but we have
to come back to that because we still
haven't voted on the other one yet that
this the sentence includes with the long
sentence I think we could do it all did
you did did we vote on that do you have
a vote on that sentence well we've
already had two votes well then we did
yeah we did we voted on that so now we
can vote on this okay before we do um
I'd like to just bring up school board
shall develop and we had discussed this
early on but do we want to say Implement
versus adopt a policy School Board shall
develop and Implement a policy well
first they have to adopt
it shall develop adopt and Implement no
just develop and
adopt well if if if a school is going to
develop and adopt a policy you would
think they would also be implementing it
rather than not putting into it but I
mean why do you adopt a policy if you're
not going to do anything with it but
that's up to them well that's up to them
us
right okay but you know me like I even
consequences yeah I don't think should
be you don't foresee any difficulties if
if we do not use the word were to
implement because you believe that if
policies are if we direct that they be
adopted that they will in fact be
implemented and that we're not going to
be sitting here a year from now saying
well they didn't implement it because
okay oh yeah am I you're going to be in
57 okay yeah this is like a Sub sub
meeting over here I know this is far
worse than a
cus yes
okay I'm sorry all right School Board
shall develop we voted the first we
voted the second now we've got a
replace the first sentence with the
following sentence such board shall
develop and adopt a policy governing
and other personal electronic
communication device usage in schools
you want the word other personal I have
and personal all right and read what you
have you start read it sounds school
boards shall develop and adopt a policy
governing student cell phone use and
personal electronic communication
devices in
schools the policy shall at a minimum
restrict the use of student personal
cell phones during class instruction
with approved exceptions determined by
the superintendent or his or her
designate with respect to student
medical disability or language
proficiency needs then it goes on to say
school district policy shall not
prohibit students with medical needs and
the
disabilities I think the very it should
say which may include the smart watches
do we want to do we have to and I those
are personal communication devices but
maybe they don't want to go there maybe
what if a what if a school district
didn't want to go into they can say that
they're
exempting ex you're by not identifying
the device you're you're you're not
saying that that device cannot be uh
utilized yeah you're just saying other
okay you identifying cell phones and
saying you cannot
evade doing something about cell phones
you can't evade this but other personal
devices are ones that you as a school
board will have to specify but doesn't
that say and what does it say in the
first sentence
sh and shall develop and okay School
Board shall develop and adopt a policy
governing student cell phone use and
personal electronic communication
devices theyve got to include the
personal in there they need to okay
yeah um because you can respond back and
forth to
text so do we
really so School Board should develop an
adopt a policy governing School cell
uh okay we do need to say in schools
because it's the first sentence all
right oh wait a minute I'm sorry in
public and Charter
Schools uh is that school doesn't I mean
charter school doesn't have a school
board right they have a board of
directors oh shoot okay Board of
Trustees so that's why you gota be we
bodies a school board is a governing
body a Board of Trustees is a governing
School governing bodies would that would
that I do
well he's doing that what you know every
school has a governing
body I just want to make sure that we've
got medical disability and language
those are all down here you know what I
mean we identify or Board of Trustees of
Charter Public Charter Schools down here
like I think it would be great if we
could just do the three here and Define
them down here um all right so the
suggestion is that we indeed be specific
rather than use the term governing
bodies we say school boards or of Tres
or Board of Trustees of char of a
chartered public school okay so wait so
School boards or the Board of
Trustees of Chartered public well no
you've going from plural to singular
shall develop and adopt a policy
governing student cell phone use in
schools okay so um school boards okay is
am I capitalizing the C in chartered in
Charter Public Schools no no right okay
so School boards or the Board of
Trustees of Chartered Public Schools
shall develop and adopt a policy
governing student c phone use and
personal electronic commun communication
devices in schools
well the word
use cell
phone or personal the use get phone use
and then we just got the devices hanging
on the
end do we want the word use after
phone cell phone use and see what I'm
saying usage no usages use isn't the
word I mean use is okay but it sounds
like cell phone use I think or
devices no no no it's not or it's and
right well then you got and the use of
you know what I mean you to I thought of
that I just said was the TR was red yeah
the word use or governing student cell
phone and personal can't way over there
though even about the use of govern
about the cellon how about the usages
the usages of scho of the usages of
adopt a policy governing the usages of
student cell phones and other electronic
personal communication devices cell
phone is singular so you got us are you
okay with usages it's not a very pretty
word how about the use of the use of all
right use of use of personal student
cell phon
and other personal electronic
communication devices in schools okay
all right yeah that works get the word
you those other things was hanging do
you actually have that I do but I have I
do I do have two more questions so
before we all right before we vote on
that sentence Oh no we can vote on the
sentence can we vote on the
sentence
so yes but I'm just going to read you
that and that will be before we vote on
entirely move and replace I'm still I'm
still baffled that we have to vote on
Senate for Sen and we did
the on well because we didn't know how
far we were going to go with this it is
now clear that since we have torn the
whole paragraph apart that we're going
to do a removing replace and that's the
only thing that we're going to have to
report to to the committee not that we
did this this this and we don't have to
do a play byplay okay in my view what
we're gonna do is ultimately we're gonna
we're gonna send one recommendation
to the full committee it's a remove and
replace paragraph Roman 5 with the
following language okay yep so we need
to vote on that sentence and then we can
vote on the remove and replace all right
School boards or the Board of Trustees
of Charter Public Schools shall develop
and adopt a policy governing the use of
student cell phones and personal
sorry it's okay I just didn't want
to okay the use okay school boards or
the Board of Trustees of Charter Public
School shall develop and adopt a policy
governing the use of student cell phones
and other personal electronic
and I don't think you need to read the
sentence back just because you changed
the word or to and
Bute do we have a do we have a motion on
that so moved second it moved and
seconded all in favor I'm sorry you got
to call the rooll okay representative
Hall yes representative witfield is yes
representative Terry yes
okay
replace which will be the reportable
recommendation to the full
committee uh now and then the final one
is we have we have to decide what we're
going to do with the date and then we
have to decide what we're going to do
with these bills and the appropriation
you guys don't want an appropriation do
you no I I just think it's premature
well
so chairman cordelli has recommended
that once we finish all of our word
smithing here today
that we recommend that the early Bill be
retained that preserves it and we don't
have to act on that
bill his preference is that we continue
to give the full committee an
opportunity to work with both the bills
and decide what they want to
do so regardless we can make a
recommendation but that's that is his
reference that we do not choose one of
these two bills and say we recommend
this bill over the other bill because
they're they're
identical and we we we kick it upstairs
where that decision should be made
upstairs meaning the full committee
made so we have we have two three things
to do here two or three we're going to
remove and replace with all of these
changes and it's it'll be a new five so
a motion to the effect that we remove
and replace section
five uh Roman
five with the previous
changes then gets us a clean paragraph
to send
over can you
will read the whole thing just the whole
thing as is right now it should be right
now this is what we're going to send to
the committee school boards and the
Board of Trustees of chared public
schools shall develop and adopt a policy
governing the use of student cell phones
and other personal electronic
communication devices in schools the
policy shall at a minimum respect
restrict the use of student personal
cell phones during class instruction
with approved exceptions determined by
the superintendent or his/ her design
with respect to student medical
disability or language proficiency needs
School District policy shall not
prohibit students with medical needs
parentheses EG insulin pumps and glucose
sensors closed parentheses or
disabilities from using a device to
support their learning as identified by
their individualized education program
plan developed under Section 504 of the
rehab Act of
1973 29 USC 794 or when required to
support emergent multilingual students
with appropriate language access
programs and services pursuant to the
1964 that's it is there a motion to
adopt that as the remove and replace
language for Roman five I don't know
whose turn it is sure so moved okay
second okay further discussion oh ready
representative Hall yes representative
unanimous um just to keep this clean I'm
going to recommend that we
resend the um actions that we took with
respect to the of the first three votes
we can just get rid of those now because
we've already done this so if I could
have a motion to the effect that we
resend the actions that we took with
respect to all
previous um um actions previous to the
um the motion to remove and replace I
make a motion is there a second I'll
second are we ready to vote okay
representative representative Hall yes
representative litfield yes yes
represent Terry
so do we want to do anything with the
effective
dates um one is 60 days the other is
July 1st 2025 if we vote
to uh
retain
131 no uh 781 FN we don't really need to
bother with that that is something that
the full committee can do fairly easily
is determine what date it wants can I
ask um see if it makes a difference
um Barett with respect to July one or
days you know say 60 days after
law
yeah poliy to that
schol
Association
jcy process
don't
January definitely make that 9 days
little I can't imagine that this is
going to get signed into law very very
late I would expect that it would be
signed into law it govern so 60 days is
going to give you plenty of
date I mean I just suggest I I
personally think we should keep it clean
and it should be either implemented
prior to the first day of school or the
beginning of the second semester of the
school year because this is going to be
it's going to be a huge culture shock I
don't think like let's say mid- October
makes sense do you know what I'm saying
I think it should be a clean
cut
but but but once again we had the
discussion you know hours
ago um the actual take effect on such
and such a date that doesn't mean the
policy is going to go into effect on
that date because that's the date when
the school boards are notified that they
have to do this so they have to be given
sufficient time in order to develop and
to uh adopt the policy so we want to we
want an earlier date rather than a later
date because it's already going to take
policy effective after that's fine but
not to undo the work but you say by
January 2026 shall have well no but
before you came we we we we put an X
through that okay right I'm just tell
you
from because because you said I believe
you said that with respect to um adopt
that there would be compliance and and
that they weren't going to push it's
unlikely they'd be pushing out the
effective date of the school's policy
years
okay
yes
first does that mean that the policy has
to Beed by the first day of school I
don't know how it could be that's only
four weeks correct so my point is my
question
that that's how we always interpret so
if it says the actual take
effect that means that's when the policy
should be in place that's how you're
interpreting that because the Act is the
act is is the asking you to develop a
policy the ACT is telling you to develop
a policy it doesn't tell you when you
place School Association we've always
interpreted the bill says eff days after
pass and then requ policy within that
bill you've always intered that have to
push outc
ready to go well if that's the if that's
the common practice and a common
understanding then then all we have to
do is decide when we want this to be
implemented because then we'll make that
the effective date that the actual take
effect 90 days after passage 60 days
after passage or a date certain I ask
another question so I mean is it
reasonable to think that in September of
2025 that this would be ready to go okay
so it's sign
law by Easter
okay January
one January
one well let me ask you this I don't
here's part of where I'm lost on this is
I personally think it should be the week
before Labor Day right because that's
when most I know it's soon but I'm just
saying it's no secret that this is out
there the governor has been saying this
for the past several weeks that doesn't
mean anybody's been doing anything about
it right but it just sounds so reactive
I don't understand why it wouldn't be on
the school board's radar or why we
couldn't start working on policies
now I know you need the exact wording
but you're gonna they're gonna have some
idea between once it goes through the
Senate
no uh so if if this bill were signed
into law in April you mean you have
other policies you could not have you
think it's unrealistic to have schools
adopting and it's unrealistic for them
to to develop and adopt a a what could
be very well a model at at the very
least model School Board Association
policy to implement September
1st let's just say by May 1 pushing it
somewh out but not that out yeah you
could definitely have mod policy out by
the end of that over
summer
okay it is you start of
I think it'll be I think it'll be not
that it will be easy but it'll be easier
then I I personally though I would say I
like that September 1st is clean I would
back into it so that it's the actual
first day of
school you know well what's wrong with
sept well wait a minute not all schools
date for the effectiven of the policy
or we can't say no later then that
that's too squishy I would say by August
25th that that's can we can you know we
got to get August 25th I think so I
don't know I'd like to say are you okay
with August
25th do you because you're going to have
a model policy before then and they're
going to be able to work on it and they
can
is that is that a Monday what are we
talking about Monday you're saying that
you don't think any schools will start
before then so you're capturing all the
schools August 25th if you have August
25th are you are we capturing all the
schools if it's August 25th we don't
know
that are we gonna worry about
one we do September one if we do
September one just August 25th it's a
strange date it's a strange it is a
strange date
September one if you take September one
start August 28th
they impl it on
August yeah okay I mean it's not like
you know they can they can get away with
it for six days and then all of a sudden
on the first all the cell phones are
going to go
away that's not going to
happen that's the fear right that
there'll be no policy for six days and
all of a sudden there'll be a
policy okay so where do I unless you
want to say at the beginning of the
school year but there is no such date
date all right so we would need that
with respect to the effective dates in
both
bills the dates shall be we should we
recommend that the effective dates with
respect to both bills be September 1
yes okay so all that I've done is I have
have taken line 13 see how it says three
I put effective date and I put this act
shall take effect September 1st
2025 right okay so I'm going to make a
motion to that effect do have a is there
a second do it have to say after passage
does it have to say did you add that I I
just it doesn't need to the ex here
September
one forget it that is there a second
second call the role please um
representative Hall yes representative
litfield is yes representative Terry yes
okay okay um so here we we did not take
out the appropriation or make any
recommendations with respect to the
appropriation in 781 all right so we're
I think we send both bills over and the
full committee can decide whether it
wants to include any money or not I I
you know and that's I think a with what
we've done here I think it's marvelous
but for us to sit here and make our
recommendation about whether it should
be money isn't going to amount to a hill
of beans because once it gets over there
you're going to get everybody's opinion
as to whether that should be and nobody
here is going to carry the weight with
respect to that I mean I don't have that
influence so that being the case um I I
would recommend that we have a motion to
uh recommend that uh HP 781 FN be
retained because it has to be acted upon
by Wednesday
okay even though I disagree even though
I don't support it I will make a
recommendation no you make the
recommendation I don't make the
recommendation to is there a second I'll
second it okay call the rooll please
representative Hall yes representative
litfield and representative Terry
yes so in effect now we're sending over
two identical bills except for the fact
except that we are saying that we have
no recommendation about the one but we
say that we recommend that the other be
retained so by not saying anything about
the bill that does not have an early
date then this gives the committee chair
the latitude to
schedule uh further consideration of
both
bills later on in the months of March
April whatever I I have the sense that
this is not going to be sat on it's
we're going to act on this soon can I
actually take my vote back back on that
on the retained I mean I think there
shouldn't be any money on this at this
point we're not so if I do that if I
vote no on the retained it's still going
to be two to one it's still going to be
two to one yeah let's do it two to one
and I just feel like we're kicking hand
either huh I don't want to retain it
either oh why don't we just let see the
let the committee decide is that okay
with you chairman Terry um that's what I
would
rather yeah if we don't have have an
agreement here that we recommend retain
that we're kicking it to the full
committee as to what they want to do and
and you know what the full committee is
going to do what it wants to do anyway
they're either
gonna they're either going to accept or
reject the retain and somebody can
recommend retain and they don't need us
to do that so um I had no idea how this
was going to go today and I just want to
thank both of you I've never cheered a
subcommittee before that's great uh and
I I I think I think all of us did a
really fine job with with help from the
panut the bleachers and thank you for